you
filled up for some more bullet
can I do so if you want to jump into
this one at the moment here you go
tournament hourly bullet arena and
you're there at the moment there are 21
let's be 22 all right 25 minutes to go
only maybe missed out on one game
let's see who we get let's see if I can
play faster
phanzig Sicilian I was ready but I was
ready to do the caro-kann fishing poles
all right let's try this little setup
see what happens let's just see what
happens
it's different
all my piece is ready to roll here we go
i over committed on the queenside p3
drops upon this is a killer night killer
night ooh dark squares are in trouble
okay they went down it's not too common
to see Bishop c5 and then d6 that Bishop
may be a bit too exposed out there and
c5 and subject to night attacks but
seemed to work out all right with that
one try Queen exchange go for that Oh
allowing me to inconvenience your king
93
bunny three in the night on d2 I
expected this at some point let's go
queenside right now
and be a manoeuvre males be play more
aggressive
Bishop might be trapped careful now
after that move I'm not sure though it
sold my ground hold hold control over
'if I've threatening it now takes here
you have to push I'll just play active
rook on an open file and got this lined
up no I don't want to give this square
up Pat MOU
King you'll be cozy here keep that night
under control these two pawns control
the night that's not a safe square
and pieces have good squares let's push
try that where's the king going no let's
not exchange bishops are struggling
peace alright not quite sure why I'm
shedding upon like this let's get some
space how where's that Bishop go where
is that Bishop go it's kind of under
control now
kind of under control and I thought I
was going to take with the night there
they wanted that they were not caught in
a pre-move okay there they were all
right back to tournament got a couple in
there 42
still 21 to go it's 10 more games
already
efore let's go open Sicilian Whiteside
this time okay we'll go fine kiddo
double pawns
all right
oh let us see
push that night build my Center okay
open the up file
I want this diagonal to open up be a
little bit careful my king
let's jump in I'm in a pin I don't know
why exactly I'm doing it like this that
was silly it's a strong night their
night is strong that Queen can be
attacked okay good take here take my
night no I'm definitely worse here
that got away from me
yeah that wasn't uh that was sloppy for
sure
for sure let's go one
not here oh hang on hang on hang on
careful careful they have to give up the
exchange now ooh
they could have blocked and went on just
threw in the towel all right
Dragons eel next opponent let's go at
the trio space
all right
secure that stop 9h five and maneuver
right now right now just in time I have
very good control over this position
very good control prepared to take with
the palm and in the end I glue a knight
in there
oh they have this pawn it's a little bit
too fast now there's no good pawn breaks
for my opponent I could Castle in this
direction and exchange off one of their
nights now just kick them all away
these aren't holes just sidestep their
threat for starters this night he
remains a monster now they get flushed
back like a push because this nice
hanging space okay that's an interesting
sequence get in there or a mobile pawn
I'm going to stick my other night right
here these Knights are killers
everything is locked they could only go
back and forth let's tuck my King in
they have to resort to shuffling and we
give made on h8 soon
take that bishop yeah there's nothing to
do there
it all begins with at f5 square
and their bishop wasn't able to do much
g-seven control f5 you're controlling
some other stuff
the bishop
okay let's go here let's see if they
push here to the blunder or a mistake
one of the two
I take here with the night and then the
rook is overloaded as soon as the night
takes Sneaky stead of castles there okay
it's Castle and contest this file I want
this square for my king
could have considered that but I'm
playing with fire a little bit
let's give them a kick now
you
defend with the rook I gotta watch out
for f5
centralize the night
watch out for c4
strong bishop like I did in that game
against Captain Obvious um how do I want
to take take it the bishop keep the
structure as is okay with one rook okay
now
lock it down I had still have an extra
pawn still have an extra pawn didn't
want to go there
my king of watch over these I get to
swipe upon prove the king okay
they were down on the clock
got 2014 in change to go
let's see
hello Aidan h32 in the twitch chat
let's go Sicilian again
all right now the bishop has to
passive
you
let's play with this
all right they're giving me a square
let's let's make use of that might want
to snip one of these too
I remove this night so he's a tough guy
all right game on
Stewart
careful let's go like this get the F
file
go with the rook I want to be able to
double continue I could have captured
straightaway do it now
oh we got the OL made on h2
and see that into the last position
there
key defender of h2 was removed night on
f1 night on f8 no mate
fa f1
soon he was as as soon as he was gone
a Iran Turk t5o
you five let's try and be a pest with my
light square bishop
I feel like this is really close to
winning strategically this night is so
strong and even if challenged that would
mean well if challenged I don't really
have to react I could support them and
now there's this file so I don't really
have to Castle I keep my king in the
center
um actually let's go with the Queen
exchange I have a superior King and King
position in superior structure I believe
I could pivot here a really strong King
post Kings in the corner forthright King
hey they get a passer or win upon its
defendant
oh I didn't see that
but I could now push and then go here
next so I'm removing the block hater and
improving the king
you
and a sneak in a Jeep pawn advance there
it is my rook is way too fast though
yeah they resigned
okay I'm gonna games to that eight
twenty eight twenty sixteen fourteen
eighty are in here now okay I see
chatter man one is in there
Royal be alright
Oh a Dutch
mmm I'm forgetting the setup I go with
ok I'm gonna I'm gonna work with this
yeah let's go here Night Moves yeah this
is now really weakened this one for two
reasons here but this I could take the
rook I'll do that
I'll take here if there's a pawn capture
then I peel open the F file let's just
prepare for that in case they want to
shut it down yeah
centralize and I'm ready to crash
through here Queen exchange oh oh no no
no no what a bad mouth slip I want to
wreck a four oh no ahhh what can you do
not too much
ah
can I somehow be dangerous okay I'm on
the knight from getting more activity
than I should
then I should
ah awful
Oh what can you do less than 8 28:20 no
fire for me these two have fire
okay Mahalo throw me in a game
the killer three three three let's try
let's throw a game in there where I have
c3 why not
h3 too slow h3 may have been too slow
d5 may have been a good follow up d5
right now even alright let's let's try
this where I have a pawn here
this guy and now I have a clear sight
let's go right here clear sight of the
kingside what kind of weaknesses are you
gonna give me dark square weaknesses
let's make use of it right away and give
this pawn up for what reason I don't
have a good reason okay
they could have probably captured here
ah better bishop at least I have some
rogue activity against the killer
and I want this pawn to go any further
down far enough exposed
Paul may have gone a bit too far maybe I
have rook activity compensation for sure
how much now it's even now it might be
close to me king is living dangerous
that's me
okay got 30
20s for with fire though seeing a game
is in the game 92 are in here okay mm
maybe we try Benoni now let's still play
c5 okay
it implies c4
I'll take hmm all right two to one in
the center they have built up my central
presence there see what they do about B
- nothing
dropping stuff
I'll take b2 queen takes a for Queen
takes b2
let's defend the pond Oh let's keep them
around I want to target that one day
plight square how can we get there ow I
want a knight right here
Oh around my night it's good thing they
don't of a dark square bishop around I
still want to get at that bun Queen
Qatar get it there you go
finally now we have a serious passed
pawn serious here first then there
got a sneaky move here here back rank
made ideas win the pond no time for rook
D too because of the back rank way tap
on way down on the clock by the way
Oh sneaky town sneaky control the fee
keto square control the fee and keto
square and then we got a mate in a few -
in this case whoa I had less than three
seconds
too much thinking
less than now it's called three
let's go Sicilian fishing pole why not
it's close to me very close to me
lights are dark square weaknesses I
think this was necessary
on the exchange my clean is a rock on
the e5 a rock
defense sky right here
let's go here some support okay who do
not see that move
why did I take that pawn let's take the
knight Queen here
take take run or just that
I move about
okay just throw in a quick check okay we
got ten point gap 99 are in their last
game coming up of the tournament
Panama on fire let's try e4
let's get the H pond running line up
let's go with this - giving up a big
square
yep okay take it what they thought I was
taking it upon I want to take with the
Panda flush that away I will take that
let's
simplify let's take a pond be a little
bit greedy and another one now we'll
exchange Queens where's the king gown
can I check me around a little bit
whoa okay a little scary to have to go
into the corner okay this is really poor
technique what which has happened here
really poor really really poor what's
going on right now
okay drop another pawn
this is awful what's happening right now
14 seconds each how did it get to this
point
can I finally get running with this poem
can we finally get pushing this pond
ugly technique just take that pond
oh I lost that one I could get so
frustrated - Creek oh man I should why
did I put my king in the corner
put your king on D - next time and be
happy d2 d3 who cares if you drop the a
p-- a-- a hundred total in that one
final standings 36 26 26 21 it seemed
all how many get in there twelve that
counted hundred page one
let me refresh it's not moving there we
go
page two
three four five six seven eight nine
almost everyone there that is everyone
okay
nobody chatted to the 99 of you good
games all
you